good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday which
should be just terrible but here's why
it's not Jax ready I think I know why
one we're together and like seriously
how bad can life be when I'm sitting
here with my sis Life's good two it's a
short week we've got
a holiday weekend a bank holiday
whatever you want to call it this
weekend don't fret it's really you think
about it Tuesday
technically speaking Yeah if you want to
get technical yeah no it's very very
exciting to be embarking on a shirt week
is that what you thought I was gonna say
no we have a really exciting afternoon
planned oh we do that just puts a pep in
the step yeah it's a big uh BHD I don't
know if you guys know what that is BHD a
big hairy day we got big plans with
Harry yeah Harry kind of like scheduled
time with me last week today I cleared
my schedule and I kind of got like extra
dressed up I showed a little leg for her
loves a little leg I think he'll find I
feel like he could play with the prickly
hairs on my legs they're like
fascinating I feel like you could play
with that for like 30 minutes
we'll give him a shot yeah we'll see
what he says it's gonna be his first
time at the studio it is and I don't
know I guess we should have like cleaned
up or something like on some balloons I
don't know yeah no he he loves chords
and he loves lights he's gonna free he
loves cords and lights feels like maybe
he's taking after his auntie and wants
to work in I.T maybe you're kind of been
his mentor like yeah I would say Muse
but sure yeah his what is that called
inspiration like a person I guess a
mentor yeah but like it's not a strong
enough word for what Harry and I have
yeah do you have a mentor
that's a really good question I think I
would say ins not in all walks of life
but in many walks of life I would
consider Brian a mentor of mine yeah
like about business and money when you
have a mentor it's like established that
they're your Mentor like now when I
think I text Brian and say like do you
think you're right about the tour no no
that sounds like you're accusing him of
oh you're right the mentor
would you say
that you're my mentor like I kind of
feel like when people have a mentor it's
like a conversation they have like will
you be my mentor do I know there's like
an interview like there's like a
declaration you're like they're Chosen
One and vice versa and it's a very
flattering to be someone's Mentor but
it's also a huge opportunity to be a
mentee I also feel like in a lot of ways
like you're my mentor because when I
think about like okay if I have a
decision to make who do I call yeah like
you Mom Brian but like a mentor is
someone who is like intentionally
shepherding you
through the workplace really and your
career and like I'm just your big sis
and I love to give you advice that's why
I didn't say you at first because it's
like so obvious like my mentor I feel
like Brian honestly yeah but he's also
your friend like I think that's the best
type of Mentor mentee relationship for
sure but he's like not
textbook Mentor no no we're but we've
never been traditional girlies me and
Brian you know that's true just breaking
you know glass ceilings and such I feel
like people
towards any morning shows I think it's
definitely like an outdated concept but
it's a nice one but I just I don't know
how to get linked up with a mentor I
certainly don't have them no I think
it's definitely hard to find a mentor
which is why when you have one it's like
such a sacred Bond and relationship yeah
you don't go through mentors like you go
through bosses like yeah no and like
whatever company you go to like they
still mention that at one company like
they're still your Mentor they're still
menting they kind of Mentor you forever
it's a lifelong thing I feel it's kind
of a really sweet relationship and I
feel like there should be more of them
well I'll keep you posted Brian hasn't
answered me yet so
I'll keep you posted on whether it's a
mutual but it's like if we needed if we
got mentors they would have to be like
kind of big wigs in entertainment or
broadcasting yep
who's your dream Mentor OH my dream
Mentor Dead or Alive Joan Rivers alive
Clarkson yeah Kelly
like Taylor like obviously but it's like
such a lame answer I don't know but like
really like Kelly Works in every space
that like I want to work in yeah
furniture furniture including um talk
show right right you know what I mean I
actually think that she could be of
service to me I don't know I don't
really feel like there's anybody out
there who I would want to be my mentor
thus just kind of propelling me forward
to be the mentor I wish to see in the
world that's beautiful like I hope
there's millions of young girls out
there saying my dream Mentor is Claudia
you know would you Mentor anyone sure
like I dabble
I feel like you dabble too because you
are shut up the influencer mentor
their mentors yeah Jack basically just
call me old but no I I've gotten
comfortable with the title but that's
really like actually what you were just
referring to yeah when you said you
dabble yeah you are kind of an
influencer Mentor there are like a bunch
of girlies who I think seek out my
advice
pretty frequently and I'm more than
willing to give yeah I feel like I've
actually made some really pop like
especially Remy like when Remy has an
issue I feel like she actually comes to
me a lot and I feel like I get very
sound Sage advice
the influencer mentor yeah that should
you kind of spoke it into existence I
well I was just
picking up what you were already putting
down right
still no response from Ryan just
checking I feel like a mentor should
respond sooner yeah no I agree it's kind
of like well I guess not maybe he's so
busy responding to his actual mentees
perhaps not perhaps not I feel like he
actually is a certified mentor to other
people for sure like because he comes
from the corporate world definitely
definitely
um so it's so great to be back with you
Jax it's such a crazy busy weekend
because I watched everything on the face
of the planet I watched American Idol
last night which we're going to talk
about because we have it as a story it
was the finale I watched I started Queen
Charlotte the Bridgerton prequel it's
very good
I watched
succession
Zach watched succession while I read oh
so I caught bits and pieces but I didn't
watch last week either because I'm out
and I'm done there's no such thing on a
spoil as a spoiler and a show that where
nothing happens it's horrible last night
was the funeral I I caught bits and
pieces oh
never ending yeah well at least it ends
next week oh is it ready Latin next week
is the series finale the thing is is
like I was trying to think of this
morning like my thoughts on the show so
I could share them on today's episode
and you know a lot of people compare it
to Yellowstone because it's like about a
family business succession and I feel
like there have been Parts in times in
Yellowstone where like the plot wasn't
plotting you know yeah right now but the
characters are so loved beloved and
really I could watch them do anything
and I would love it and I feel like
every episode on succession they chip
away at the last few things you might
have liked about a character like Roman
like they just get like they'd strip you
of that so you don't even care like when
crazy things are happening to them bad
or good you literally don't [__] care
yeah you don't like these are morally
corrupt depraved people like they have
no
they've nothing like nothing even
remotely you'd think okay like Kendall
something's going on with the kids like
maybe that's something no that elicited
a reaction for me like why should
Kendall of custody full custody of his
kids of course not did she even know
them no but like his kids like one of
his daughters like was like attacked or
something and he like didn't care like
so it's like even like the last line of
like I didn't care I thought he cared I
thought I caught that he cared no the
mom was freaking out and wants to get
them out of town he was like you're
being dramatic and now he wants custody
and now he wants custody yeah that he
wants custody because like the mom is
just being like overly protected like
what qualifies you to have custody
literally like you're so it's like even
like the like okay you're kids like even
that they don't care about anything they
stand for nothing and so you really just
you can't feel bad for them you can't
celebrate their success and that's why
the show in my opinion like is a flaw
because of course not every season of
Every show is gonna have the best
writing you would hope you know the
final season it would but if even on a
show where like whatever the writing
plot sucks you love the characters what
I've seen people say is like no we love
Tom and Greg like oh no I don't that
they're the loved there the comic relief
maybe they're a little bit funny but
they too like stand they stand for loss
they stand for less like they're just
obsessed with like because they're
Outsiders so it's like they're even more
desperate yeah for success and money and
fame and like there there's like this
big scandal at ATN and like all they
care about is like their names being in
it like they're the two of the biggest
losers ever like at one point I found
them comical for sure but no the show is
so bad and like I will not people are
like Claudia you don't get it it's
satire like you just have a low bar for
comedy like this [__] literally sucks it
sucks and you literally cannot convince
me otherwise eat my ass [__] you just
have a low bar for comedy eat my ass
[__] yeah and that's the succession
recap oh that's all you truly need to
know I'm not gonna bore you with my
recap of the most boring 90 minutes they
made it it was like 80 minutes I'm like
you're kidding me right I know I saw I
was like waiting for it to be over so is
that Bruno out and it was like still 30
more minutes yeah same I'm like I paused
I'm like Ben this is done in a minute
you can come back and
20 more minutes yeah but I will say your
Recaps of bad shows usually are some of
my favorites usually make me actually
interested in the show like you actually
got me watching succession for a few
more episodes because of the way you
recap that letter
um and then another Morgan letter the
Morgan lot oh that was a good that's
what I thought the season was going to
be good I thought like the whole time
we'd be trying to decipher this letter
kind of like Game of Thrones energy
um and then I also watch pretty much all
of that show I told you to watch what is
Game of Thrones if not a succession
exactly
I watched somebody somewhere that
Bridget Everett show I told you that you
would like you would like it it's
basically like shit's creek but
everyone's depressed yeah I thought you
said it's depressing it is but it's got
heart and it's Bridget Everett is great
she's great and it's funny but it's like
depressing you know everything's
depressing and that's just not my vibe I
know I know I know you gotta like
protect your your piece yeah so I I
actually didn't watch a lot of TV this
week and I started our book for the
redheads which actually it's called
avika in the Hollywood wives and it's
like all about Hollywood and
celebrity movie stars whatever and this
morning when I was looking through the
stories I was like so in the world of
the book that I was like no that this is
what's happening in Hollywood because
there was like all this drama yeah and
it really tripped me up but the book is
really good so far my book club meets
tonight about the the flop of the
century the Flop the things in which we
left unfinished by Margot washer yeah
that Margaret recommended I feel guilty
I feel like by association like the book
I don't know if I think I don't know if
everyone hated it as much as I do but
this is the first time in book club
history that we actually postponed
because people hadn't finished it yet
that's not a good sign right that's not
a good sign and I don't really believe
in like postponing me neither for that
reason no me neither and I think we you
know the book club learned a valuable
lesson because once we postponed
everyone was like I can't do this week
we we plan a month in advance and
everybody plans their month around it so
unfortunately Natalie's not gonna make
it tonight which just sucks you know I'm
a member of the community not being able
to come she's on her honeymoon and so
it's like we learned like you don't move
like book club is immovable because once
you do we're lucky we got another tape
even if people don't finish the book
like they can still come and talk about
up until what they read yeah
but I think that also sets a bad
precedent I think no because some books
like art dnf I know but I think like a
prerequisite for attending book club is
like you just have to read the book I
think it's okay if you
usually did not finish the book like you
don't have to finish every book that you
start if you really don't like it and
then you come in and you share why you
disliked it so much and you're
contributing to book club but like
that's what I'll be doing tonight at all
stay home yeah yeah well that's what
I'll be doing I'll be like negative
Queen today at the club for you me too
well the redheads are actually recording
this week instead of next week because
of the holiday people's travel schedules
so we're all reading the book earlier
and it's a great book great month to
join the redheads always the redheads
book club
trbc trbc trbc greater than TCBY Beyond
and that's that's a high bar because
TCBY really is the country's best yogurt
is that franchisex still intact I think
in some places I literally have this
conversation like once a year
I don't feel that way really we've had
it in regards to trbc TCBY yeah no I
think it's like not as prestigious as it
once was and as ubiquitous but I think
it's still around
Brian responded what did he say I said
would you say that you're my mentor he
said I mean aren't we each other's
mentors in unbridled chaos so basically
no so no
so basically no ask him do you have like
official like mentees do you Mentor
people are you taking on new mentees so
basically what you're saying right word
is I'm not your mentee yes it is the
right word
do you have actual mentees
and I feel like Brian does have a mentor
I just cannot recall who it is for sure
he does I'm fairly certain
um
his name is Rick
that's so Mentor yeah he's the guy the
mentor he's the guy he works at Brian's
parent company and he's the one who was
on Sully's flight that landed in the
Hudson remember how could I forget and
Brian held an event where Rick who was a
passenger on that flight and Sully
reunited and they gave him an award and
it was beautiful we were there it was a
beautiful night is it just a coincidence
that Brian's Mentor like is kind of part
of the biggest story in the last century
or
I believe it's a coincidence
yeah beautiful that's the beauty that
comes from a mentor mentee relationship
that's the power of Sally That's The
Power of zala
yeah
so we've got a great show right anything
else we need to catch up on girly swirly
twirly dearly no we had a nice weekend
to spend some time together we had
brunch
we had brought it meant nothing to you
no we did have brunch but also the day
before that we did something long
overdue for our patreon oh my God we did
I wanted to talk about that on the show
today because I took some of the tips
that you gave me just really one for
today which was more blush
and I'm going to get a cream Contour
stick I think you should I used to use
one but then I just felt like I would
use cream contour and then bronzer
Contour so just felt like an unnecessary
step so but I feel like my face could
use a little more definition these days
so like two years ago was it when we sat
down a year ago okay a year ago Jackie
and I had the idea for patreon episodes
on you know any given month that we
would do this little Series where Jackie
does her makeup tutorial on me like I do
Claudia's makeup in the style of me and
I do Jackie's makeup using her products
in the style of her we did mine it was
such a success I like took away so many
little tips and tricks I loved the way
that I looked I was nervous but it ended
up being a great piece of content cut to
literally trying to schedule the
appointment to do Jackie's wake up and
it's been a year it's been a year and
this week I said [__] sit the [__] down
oh no it's probably been two years yes
yeah I keep thinking like like I don't
think I was pregnant right thank you two
years yeah so on Friday we actually did
it I got to do Jackie's makeup it was
not what I thought it was going to be it
was an extremely tense I would say toxic
work environment there were butts there
were
there was drama that's what I'll say
there was drama I won't spoil it I feel
like I tried to tell you guys like over
the years how I really don't like being
touched I don't let anyone touch my face
and like no one's really listening
listened taken me seriously like
believed me yeah and now you know and
now you know that I'm not joking okay
that I [__] hate when people touch my
face but people were then saying like
how do you you don't get facials right
no when it is a professional like wow
not no shade to turdy Lou wow no shade
to turdy Lou who picked her scab before
she started my makeup I did when I'm in
it do it again when I'm in a
professional environment like a facial
and even when I get my makeup done by a
professional like I'm a normal person
there's a level of you know cleanliness
that comes with like professionalism
like you don't have to worry I know what
you mean yeah like they're using you
know tools that have been sanitized I
don't think about it also when I'm
getting a facial like I if I'm not
wearing makeup I mind less when people
touch my face
um and I just sort of give myself over
to the process like it's really not a
big deal but the idea of Friendly Fire
touching my face like
no you guys it was the craziest thing I
truly ever seen in my life like you
seriously need help
okay fine I need help okay fine like
I'll take it it is what it is yeah
I can't help I am who I am you yam who
you yam and that's okay and that's okay
we got it all on camera patreon.com I
feel like I've been trying to tell you
guys you know you have and no one like
understood where I was like that I was
being for real yeah that I even said
last week when we had that hip story uh
no not this your hip
what yes your toasters about the husband
who touches the butt and she said she
doesn't want to be touched she's touched
all day and Claudia was like sometimes
Ben touches my hip and I was like yeah I
hate being touched too but blah blah
blah and I just feel like people didn't
hear that like everybody like hates
being touched but do they you
you were like seriously malfunctioning
yeah
you guys
just watch it patreon.com I don't know
what that
what that show you have for conditions
but like what is it about
I don't know
maybe that'll be the next patreon Vlog
we get you we take you to get diagnosed
yeah like take me to uh a facility to
get treatment yeah it would just be
interesting to know I have no intention
of changing no no you've got you've made
it this far I made it this far it's it's
cleaner this way yeah no and it's like
it doesn't affect my day-to-day life
except for this patreon Vlog yes well it
made for some good content so there's
that there is that patreon.com the toast
and what else can we tell you guys
before we dive into like the stories
like that aren't about us the story and
the stories that like we're not waiting
there's no breaking news I mean honestly
my week doesn't even begin until
Wednesday night you know
waiting
for Wednesday
only thing that matters in the entire
world right now I know and they should
really be doing something about it like
we need bi-weekly episodes we need
something well they're gonna be putting
like unedited not unedited but more con
more
[__] on peacock I'm a reunion like the
reunion's gonna have like deeper Cuts
they are just firing on all Bravo was
like milking this for all that it is
like getting the watch weapons live
interviews Rob uh peacock content they
had a series High rating series high
ratings on finale un finale good series
because when you told me that the
episode after scandival broke it was
like the biggest episode in two seasons
I'm like what it's not enough you know
it was a slow build like with the whole
globe everybody had to catch up so it
was the highest rated episode series
high so it was the highest rated Vander
from girls episode ever that's how it
should as it should right and I can only
imagine the reunion's gonna break that
too especially like probably part three
I don't know I think I think the people
who are not like devoted Vanderpump fans
are going to lose their patience with
the way that they do reunions I know but
that finale like not a moment not a
minute was wasted wasted it's true any
fluff there was no you know panning over
the city of L.A watching people's feet
walk across the street fake pop music in
the background yeah so true
um
so yeah
so yeah we'll see you guys on Wednesday
night Thursday morning but until then we
do have the fast five stories that you
need to know
okay just one more thing from Brian he
said he doesn't have like official ones
that he has like check-ins with
um but he said I think
he's like but I think we all Mentor each
other in ways no why do you ask
Brian that's beautiful
you know I'll just call him later and
explain that that was beautiful yeah I
think we all should be checking in and
mentoring and menteeing one another all
the time I agree with that but I also
think like it's nice to have the one of
course an official like the person who
picks you out of the crowd and also the
person that you pick and then you go to
each other will you be my mentor yeah I
feel like there needs to be more done
in the Foster to Foster these
relationships yeah because it's an old
school thing yeah but it's nice it is
nice well you know what else is nice
today's sponsor Chamberlain coffee
introducing Chamberlain coffee's new
ready to drink collection inspired by
Emma Chamberlain's daily cold brew
recipe Chamberlain coffee just launched
four plant-based latte flavors in a can
they're available exclusively at Walmart
you shake them well serve them called
for the best coffee experience so
Chamberlain coffee is ready to drink
collection lets you enjoy great coffee
with minimal effort which is fabulous
when things work out and you don't have
to do much plus it's easy to bring your
new favorite cold brew on the go so
everybody knows Emma Chamberlain queen
of coffee this has the Emma Chamberlain
stamp of approval we have the canned
beverages in our studio they're so great
to have like on the go you can leave
some at your desk at the office fridge
have them in your house if you're going
out busy Mom it's really delicious they
come in four different flavors and
they're available exclusively at Walmart
so you can take your favorite Cobra
latte on the go anytime anywhere you
have coffee on hand to grab in seconds
anytime and no prep is required the four
delicious flavors
are cold brew latte mocha latte cinnamon
bun latte and vanilla latte
um you know I'm like weird about coffee
I actually really like the vanilla one
you can find these lattes exclusively at
Walmart you can shop on the Walmart app
or online at walmart.com for easy
delivery or in-store pickup for limited
time our listeners can get a free
Chamberlain coffee latte when they
purchase a can terms and conditions
apply visit chamberlaincoffee.com the
toast for offer details that's
chamberlaincoffee.com
the toast for offer details on how you
can get a free Chamberlain coffee latte
when you purchase a can today's episode
is also brought to you by Babel if you
have an upcoming summer trip Abad abroad
our go-to travel hack is Babel whether
you're a seasoned traveler or embarking
on your first Adventure communication is
key to fully experiencing a new culture
and that's where Babel comes in Babel is
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions thanks to
Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination so
obviously having a trip planned to like
Italy France is a great reason to learn
a new language it's super you know makes
life and traveling a lot easier it's
also a lot safer you know you don't get
lost but also there's really no bad
reason to like learn a new language it's
a great thing to do as an adult to like
you know like a like a little hobby you
start it expands your mind expands your
horizons maybe you can fall in love you
know you go to France you meet a cute
Frenchman but you have this language
barrier issue Babble but Claudia That's
Amore That's Amore
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in as
little as three weeks they're expertly
crafted lessons are built around real
life you'll have practical conversations
about travel relationships business and
more you can choose from 14 different
languages with Babel and their speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent so No
One's Gonna sniff you out as like a
tacky American you know start your new
language learning Journey today with
Babel right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
toast that's Babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com toast to get up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for life thank you Claudia yeah welcome
our first story Jay-Z and Beyonce paid
cash for 200 million dollar Malibu
estate so Jay-Z and Beyonce bought an
enormous new Malibu California compound
entirely in cash TMZ reported what
entirely in cashier that came out this
morning we all saw this weekend that
they spent 200 million on the estate
which is May at the most expensive home
ever purchased in California but it's
also said to be the second most
expensive in the history of U.S real
estate it was first a New York City
Apartment that sold for 238 million wow
when you compare like what you got in
that apartment in New York to what they
got like
I'm embarrassed for the person who
bought the New York City Apartment
um and I think that that most expensive
apartment is in that new building that's
like an eyesore and it's having all
these problems like it's going to
collapse any minute so there's a couple
of those they're like these huge tall
skyscrapers that like are in the they're
so Random yeah they're in the most
random areas they're having enormous
issues like with electrical and plumbing
and it's like these people are living
200 million dollar apartments and they
can't flush the toilet yeah
um that's why I choose to rent you know
sources close to the deal told a TMZ
that they bought the all concrete home
from William Bell who's one of the
biggest art collectors in the world who
took nearly 15 years to build the
Mansion the 30 000 square foot property
was designed by Japanese Master
architect to Dao Ando who was also
behind the 57.3 million dollar mansion
that Kanye bought during his divorce
from Kim remember he bought a mansion in
Malibu that literally looked like uh yes
uh a garage yeah same architect
um originally the home was listed for
295 million dollars so they actually got
a deal
I have a lot of thoughts my first is I
cannot believe they paid all cash
because one of my favorite things that I
ever learned and probably one of the
only things I ever learned from Chrissy
Teigen was when she did a q a on Twitter
she was like do you have any questions
about like what it's like to be a
celebrity and be rich and famous and
someone asked about mortgages like you
guys are so rich you still get mortgages
and she was like yeah we just do like
you guys put you guys put down like a
hundred thousand dollars we put down 10
million dollars and we get a 50 million
dollar house yeah and I was like oh I
actually really never thought
celebrities or people of like enormous
wealth got mortgages but why spend money
if you can get it free from the bank
like everyone else so this is shocking
because when I saw this at first my
thoughts were oh they definitely got a
mortgage so they probably put down what
like 30 million yeah perhaps but
interest rates are so high right now
it's really not the time right that's
true so maybe that's why they thought it
would better to invest their money like
they're not wrong than to pay like
especially at these numbers and those
interest rates it would be an insane
monthly nut okay so that's just crazy
because like that means they gave up 200
million dollars and they still have like
other hundreds of millions to live it's
really not that crazy because I feel
like either one of them could have
bought this house and they bought it
together you know what I mean like
they're both so he's net he's valued at
1.5 million dollars billion 2.5 billion
sorry
2.5 million billion dollars and last she
was had a net worth of 450 million but
she just started her tour and she's
about to start her hair brand allegedly
so I think those numbers will go up yeah
yeah that's just fascinating to me
um also like I just don't believe that
people even know what their net worth is
no me neither because also I do believe
that Jay-Z's net worth is higher but I
feel like in terms of like cash
accessible to them Beyonce like does a
show gets paid releases a song gets paid
everything Jay-Z does is like business I
feel like everything he has is like
stuck I don't think he has like hundreds
of millions in cash lying around but I
feel like Beyonce actually does right he
has like business ventures and things
that are worth a lot of money but I
think Beyonce probably has a lot of like
money yeah not like value I agree with
that well the house is beautiful it is
but let me just say one thing because
you know I gotta critique the 200
million dollar house if I was buying a
200 million dollar house like I would
want it to feel like a house this whole
house is made of concrete I know that's
like a very La aesthetic it's but it's
very modern very cold like if I really
could build any house like my house
would not be like insanely modern it
would be like very Nancy Myers like
tufted couches Linens like it would be
huge and everything would be the best of
the best but the kitchen would look like
a kitchen where you're like gonna raise
a family not you know cook meth like
these like crazy gray surfaces like it's
so cold it's very cold it's not my style
either modern homes in general
especially like these futuristic I'm
just I'm in the past it's basically like
every house on selling Sunset beautiful
really I don't think I would ever live
in any of them except I remember
literally they got one house in Beverly
Hills that was like old school and had a
tennis court and like it was my favorite
house yeah that's more like houses that
look like homes are my style of living
yes I agree these this doesn't look like
a selling Sunset home to me though
because those ones are like super modern
in the sense that they're like all glass
this is you know obviously
futuristic yeah I think a lot of people
thought at first when this house came
out that it was a 75 million home Davina
never sold it does kind of look like it
but it's not no but that was a home that
was a home yeah
or Beverly Hills where is this this is
on the beach in Malibu yes like and so
that the land itself is worth how much
yes that's true
well I'm happy for them may they all you
know grow old there yeah and I do think
California is their like primary
residence so this will be like their
home I think their kids like will live
here full-time go to school in the
neighborhood you know
um so it's nice it's nice I'm happy for
them not at all jealous happy for them
crazy paying all cash yeah are you ready
for our next story yeah American Idol
has a new Champion oh my God we needed
to talk about this em Tangi wins season
21. look and to be honest who cares
about like American Idol winners but
this season because of em like took the
world basically so he is this very young
I think he's like 16 or 17 year old 18
from Hawaii
he his audition went completely viral
he's saying this random song Who even
knew it it's called Monsters by James
Blunt and you know he had just lost his
dad and the song is about like saying
goodbye to your dad and he was like very
emotional you know Katie Lionel Luke
they're all parents actually Luke Bryan
was talking about how that you know
after his audition he was like you know
I just got so choked up you know the
whole story with Luke Bryan how I think
his brother and his wife had passed away
now Luke and his wife are raising their
kids you know she's a mom Katy Perry
like everyone was sobbing
of course and he was so good like you
just the vocals it wasn't anything crazy
it was so simple and he played guitar
and he was just this really endearing
cute kid it went so viral Jackie they
literally were talking about him on Joe
Rogan last week what did they say so the
jelly roll jelly roll was the guest and
then last night jelly roll was on
American Idol performing with Lainey
Wilson they had so three hours
I saw a commercial for the American Idol
finale in like all the performers eight
to eleven I'm sorry
it's a lot that's not okay
um there's ads to be sold there's and
you know what they did a really good job
Clay Aiken and Ruben Studdard performed
together they like harked back to a lot
Keith Urban was like they're a big
return to American Idol Keith Urban was
a mentor and then all the three
finalists saying a Keith Urban song and
he like met with all them and Ian Tangi
he's like my Dad loved you so much like
him and my mom sang all your music
danced in the living room it was just it
was like really emotional but then
honestly listen to me the best part of
the night was like Ben ran in because I
was watching succession he was like get
out here
so he went viral for singing this James
Blunt song and then James Blunt came and
they sang the song together and neither
of them like could stop crying they
literally it was silent like they did
not sing they were just like shaking and
crying obviously I'm gonna assume James
Blunt wrote that song about his father
passing away and it was just such an
emotional night for Ian I think he knew
he was gonna win it was just everyone
was in tears like it was so beautiful
you had you will SOB you have to watch
his audition it's truly the saddest
thing of all time
um because I'm not your son
you're not my father we're just two
grown men saying goodbye and then when
James Bond came back to perform I'm like
oh my God Ian's version is so much
better I had never heard the original
song
um but they really you know that's what
American Idol does they tug at the Hard
strings they're gonna be in bed more
like sobbing it was a really good
episode and then of course EM1 which was
not shocking the other girl was actually
extremely talented and if it were any
other person she were up against like I
think she knew the nation has like
fallen in love with em and there was no
way that he wasn't gonna win yeah you
know
um that's beautiful I didn't know any of
this yeah no it was really he really
made the season like extremely relevant
I mean they were talking about Joe Rogan
and then jelly roll was like you have to
watch this and explain the whole
background and then they sat there and
they're both
yes I swear to God you know they're both
dads like it was
like em every person who watches video
like is touched by him he's like a very
special person oh on the best part they
do this thing where like all the
finalists have like a HomeTown parade
and he went back to Hawaii and like
they're so proud of him and like when he
got off the plane they were giving him
lays and doing the dances and this whole
concert for him and Jack Johnson showed
up and like they hold a moment of
silence for his dad like it was really
it was a plus TV yeah wow it was really
well done wow and I think he's gonna be
a star I mean obviously people are
making you know immediate comparisons to
him for him to Israel Kama Kawaii yes
because they're both Hawaiian and they
play guitar and they have like they do
have like a similar very soft-spoken I
think it's like a
the very traditional Hawaiian kind of
vibe and he's gonna he's he's gonna be
huge I'm telling you okay I'm gonna have
to watch that video you know you're not
gonna be okay like make sure your makeup
is you are all this makeup runs yeah
this mascara run just be alone with your
thoughts like once Harry's down for a
nap like you are not gonna be [__]
okay
the song itself is also just so sad and
I hadn't heard it and actually what
makes me feel like really kind of
special is me and Ben we haven't kept up
with the whole season but every now and
then like when we're bored we'll watch
American Idol and we watched his thing
live and we knew in that moment we
didn't even knew our witnessing history
yeah we knew he was gonna win and we
knew he was going to be special and we
were right not to make everything about
us
but Ben's obsessed with him Ben was
crying well I'm so glad that he won and
that and that people are glad that he
won yeah no it was a real celebration it
fell for the other girl she was a very
talented country singer but you know
you don't need to win these shows
winning is like a nice thing but once
you make top four you either are going
to be famous or not Gabby Barrett who
literally is a Grammy
country star didn't even win like yeah
and the other guy who win I ain't seen
him since I don't know when I don't even
know there was like two other people
Maddie and Caleb and then they were like
Jaden and I don't know if they want who
cares like winning really actually means
nothing yeah
but I'm sure in that moment like you're
on a high and then it comes down and she
was great she was really talented
and they both came out with original
songs like really American Idol is kind
of killing it wow I wonder how many I do
Wonder like how many people watch
American Idol because they were saying
when they were introducing Clay Aiken
and Ruben Studdard they were like you
know 17 years ago on this very stage
40 million people tuned in to watch
clay again and Ruben Studdard 40 million
people that's like how many people now
watch the Super Bowl which is like the
biggest event of the year yeah it's not
crazy we're all splintered off doing our
own thing siled watching alone binging
binging but also like there's the boys
we're not part of something no we're not
no I don't think it's the other
competition shows I just think it's the
nature of how we watch TV and all our
Behavior yeah yeah I know you're right
you know it used to be like this is the
one thing that's on at eight o'clock and
we're all gonna tune in for it oh and
it's good right right I mean the three
hours was like truly out of [__]
control yeah nevertheless we persisted
that's beautiful thank you I'm glad to
know about Ian I watched the 90-minute
episode of succession and I still had an
hour left of American Idol it's not
[__] crazy yeah nuts but a 90-minute
episode of succession like is also crazy
that's no commercials it's actually the
same length I mean you're so right no
commercials
100 percent
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Squarespace it is
all right you guys anybody need to start
a website you know you're getting into
blogging maybe starting a side hustle
eCommerce well Squarespace is everything
you need to sell anything Squarespace
has the tools you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments so whatever you're
selling Squarespace has merchandising
features to make your products look
their best online like video blocks
you're able to connect your social media
accounts you can get really great
insights into your traffic overview so
basically you can see how your visits
unique visitors page views are trending
over time you'll gain insight into the
top traffic sources products device
types browsers operating systems Etc and
the best part is the content ownership
so you basically own all the content
that you put on the Squarespace platform
they offer a one-click data portability
so if you want to start a podcast maybe
you need a website for your podcast if
you want to start a blog you need a
website for your blog it can be very
intimidating if you don't have like a
background in engineering or computer
science Squarespace is so easy you will
get a website up and running that looks
so professional looks like you had like
this big company of developers behind it
looks like you had a mentor that's what
it looks like
but you actually just had Squarespace
and if you check out squarespace.com
toast you'll get a free trial and when
you're ready to launch you can use the
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
so I think a lot of people are like
where do I even buy mentormentee.com
Squarespace does everything from start
to finish so once you're once you're
ready to launch your website use code
toast at squarespace.com you'll get 10
off your first purchase but head over to
squarespace.com toast for the free trial
and then when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmer's dog when
you look at bags of dog food you'll see
pictures of bright carrots juicy steaks
but then you open up the bag and you're
getting burnt little smelly little
pellets dog food needs some fresh
thinking so the farmer's dog is real
food feed your dog the dog the farmer's
dog it's real fresh healthy food it's
made with whole meat vegetables it's
gently cooked in human grade kitchens to
preserve the nutritional value of the
food
there's so many benefits like obviously
you know you want to feed your dog about
the best stuff out there but with Theo
once we switch to Fresh dog food his
breath he has had literally I just
thought that was like a Theo thing he's
just had the worst breath always there's
such a difference in his breath there's
such a difference in his energy his coat
is really shining he's very regular in
terms of his bowel movements it's
because I'm feeding him things that like
are natural you know that's that's for
Theo like the best of the best food
that's like real food right honestly the
biggest thing for me was the breath and
honestly
you can't put a price on it to to be
completely honest
um the meals arrive in pre-portioned
ready to serve packs it's conveniently
delivered on your schedule dog people
all across the country have ordered
millions of meals from the farmer's dog
it's never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food get 50 off
your first box of fresh healthy food at
the farmersdog.com toast plus you get
free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 55-0
percent off your first box plus free
shipping the farmer's dog streispo
approved Strife bro approved and that's
not a label that they just give out
Loosely no it means something it means
something next Story Taylor Swift says
she's never been this happy in all
aspects of her life during the era's
tour stop this weekend it was a crazy
weekend I restore it was I mean every
weekend is Eris tour is kind of crazy I
know Boston like is the Gillette Stadium
like has a special connection with
Taylor I think it was the first Stadium
she ever played laid like after Arenas
it was the first time she ever did a
rain show and then like that's when she
fell in love with like playing in the
rain she just has like a unique
collection to the community over there
she did get a rain show on Saturday
night I think it rained a little Friday
night but like Saturday was torrential
down for three and a half hours she
didn't stop the whole time
um they got some amazing secret songs it
was it was tough but I feel like every
city like has something special about it
that's true it's felt that way like last
week was Philly her hometown before that
was Nashville her other Hometown like
there's always an argument to be made
then like New York is gonna be welcome
to New York I just really hope that's
not the show on that like I don't know I
love that song but it's still obviously
going to be one of them yeah I think
it'll be the first night which night are
you going
I don't know because I'm still waiting
to get my tickets hopefully not the
first night yeah okay well anyways she
took a moment before performing her
track midnight her track question from
Midnight which was like such a crazy
surprise song I feel like that was the
surprise song yeah I feel like songs
from midnights like are really not
except she did your on your own kid
which everyone was like crapping their
pants over but Phil it just felt random
I feel like midnights are not contenders
like I feel like we're going deep on
like deep Cuts with the surprise songs
and to get a song that came out two
months ago it's like weird no and like
doesn't she do a lot of midnight songs
so if like it didn't make the the cut
yeah that's interesting but everyone
loves that song yeah no I just thought
it was crazy but before she I mean since
she gave them questions she also gave
them you know a fun fact about herself
um she told the crowd quote I've just
never been this happy in my life in all
in all aspects of my life ever and I
just want to say thank you for being a
part of that it's not just a tour I just
sort of feel like my life finally feels
like it makes sense so I thought I'd
play this song which brings me a lot of
happy memories I just feel like it's
such a crazy thing to say that after
being in a six-year relationship like oh
I'm out I'm so happy like it's so funny
first of all second of all I feel like
it's so interesting to me because I
could have guessed that this would have
been one of the happiest times in
Taylor's life just like based on look as
an observer
um and I feel like there were so many
years where all Taylor wanted was like
what she has now like that 1989 era
which was iconic but she was like trying
really hard to have like a million
friends and be like the biggest thing
and the best thing and have everyone
love her and once she had like the the
show outdo itself every single night
with all the guests that she was
bringing out yeah and that did and it
was really big and hype but this is like
happening in such a natural organic way
right so it's like once she stopped
trying to be that [__] she became that
[__] which I feel like is just a good
lesson for everyone you know yeah but it
took some time like it wasn't just to
I'm from 1989 trying and then to eras no
no organic like she did reputation which
was like the opposite of 1989 which is
like I hate all of you yep you'll get
nothing from me except when I give you
and you'll like it yep scraps love that
for her yeah and then lover which was I
feel like for me I love the songs from
lover but I really do feel like that era
was so put on like no it's such a shame
because the more I think about it the
thing with Taylor's music which is so
iconic is really you need to spend time
you need to like get far away from it in
order in my opinion to like really
appreciate it like every time an album
comes out like by the next album I'm now
hyper fixating on the one prior you know
and with lover I'm now in my era where
we don't like respect lover enough
because it was packaged in this like
really kind of corny corny perfect word
aesthetic where you thought it was just
gonna be like Dreamland fairy Cloud pop
music and I believe it's some of her
best work there are like probably five
or six songs on there that are probably
her best songs ever but we never like
give it the attention because it's like
silly lover and I agree with there there
is something there was something
inherently wrong with the way lover was
promoted because I don't think it was
taken seriously yeah and it just felt
like so inauthentic at the time but like
death by a Thousand Cuts Miss Americana
Cruel Summer daylight Afterglow
the Archer like those are literally some
of the best songs ever
and nobody thinks of it because it's
just like lover you know yeah
yeah but I also think then like folk
more and Evermore like she had to go
through that it kind of freed her yeah
like it showed her that she could put
out whatever she wants and that it's
gonna be like so loved she doesn't have
to do all the marketing she can drop it
like that was the first time she like
dropped an album the day after she said
she was gonna yep and it was her biggest
and it was her biggest and like everyone
just totally fell in love with it and so
then she was able to start kind of like
a new and fresh and and that brings us
to where we are now yeah yeah so back to
where she can also like celebrate
herself like this is a celebration of
her and her history yes yes you mean the
tour this tour yes
and so to hear that she's the happiest
she's ever been like I could have
guessed yeah but I also feel like yes
it's Shady to Joe because I thought I
was you know the one right literally but
I feel like in a lot of her relationship
with Joe other aspects of her life were
not as happy as they are now like her
career like she was with him you know
when she was canceled in reputation and
then reputation wasn't nominated for the
Grammy and lover wasn't and lover was
only nominated for pop vocal not like
overall so I feel like those were some
harder years career-wise and she's
saying like on all aspects of her life
that things are really good and I don't
think it's just shady towards Joe it's
just no me neither I just thought it was
like hilarious no I know I know but like
I actually think there's been so much
discourse around her relationship with
Maddie like you know sensitive like
distressed Millennials being like I'm so
disappointed and I think this was like a
very like subtle way of her saying like
I'm really happy [__] off like I'm I got
it under control like I'm 32 years old
like I know what I'm doing
you know yeah I think there was
definitely an element of that and I like
that because I like it but why do you
think this song brings back happy
memories what is it about what is this
song about I thought it was about Justin
and Selena no here's the thing the way I
have no [__] idea what question is
about can I ask you a question have you
ever had someone kiss you in a crowded
room and every single one of your
friends was making fun of you and 15
seconds later they were clapping too
what did you do what the [__] does that
mean I don't know and who who's who who
good girl sad boy big city wrong choices
we had one thing going on I swear that
it was something because I don't
remember who I was before you painted
all my nights a color I've searched for
since but one thing after another
bucking situation circumstances
miscommunications and I have to say by
the way I just made like some
explanations I have literally no idea
what's going on
I have no idea it's such a confusing
song to me it's a Bop
but I don't get it if somebody could you
know drop in the comments like what the
[__] is the song about I had heard it
was about Selena and Haley I mean not
Selena Selena Justin I still don't get
it
maybe she just has fun memories of like
writing this song you know with Jack
maybe not like the memories from the
song but the memories of writing it and
like being in the studio and just like
vibing out with heresties asking
questions maybe that just happened to be
like a really particularly fun day at
the office
sure sure
I like that let's go with that so then
some of the other secret songs you
should have said no everyone's marking
themselves safe which is so funny I
think you guys are sleeping on red no
that's really like an amazing song that
was tough no but you you were like with
your tongue out like I'm fine I am fine
because I'm waiting for peace and so any
song and and you know why else I'm fine
like I am a part of like a very blessed
group of individuals like I got
out of the woods and 15 like I am a
probably that's probably one of the top
three
surprise song combos like I feel blessed
you think so what are the others there
was one this weekend the Friday night
one let me find it hold on was really it
was really kind of Next Level stellar
there's this Instagram account that like
posts them all let me just find out I
think snitch tag yeah that's I'm
literally on snitches thing when she
marked herself safe yeah because she's
waiting for a long live which was
supposed to be last night
people just made that up I don't know
I'm sorry no one's getting Long Live do
you know what I mean you feel no one's
getting it like to give it to one group
it's uh like the fact that it's not in
the set list means it's not coming at
all I think someone's getting I don't
you see people are selling the Rainwater
on eBay I did not see that people are
not okay
you saw people selling their contacts
that when they saw in the show that I
would buy these lenses have seen Taylor
okay like why am I so you're saying
these ones oh um okay no wait so that's
sorry I'm like really having a hard time
this Instagram account's really on point
take your time um I am
oh oh oh oh this was tough for me on
Friday night they got better man
that was on my list that was like
because one thing about me and why I
feel like better and it's been more
special than everyone is like I have
loved that song
long before Taylor ever even released it
LBT and I like looked past my hatred of
Little Big Town and I saw the song for
what it was and I've had a connection to
it ever since
and I used to watch she had like one
lowly performance in this like
documentary about Bluebird Cafe that was
on YouTube and Scott borchetta is like
talking over her in the documentary
whatever I lived with that like YouTube
video for so many years like now I have
obviously other things thanks to her
re-releasing it like that was hard for
me and we'll put the other song that
night was Shoulda said no that's a
really good song and she recreated so
she was just like turnt performance at
the ACM Awards like when she was 11
years old no like 16. of should have
said no um where she's like standing in
the rain like she doesn't sound her best
but she's having fun and she does this
thing where she changes the Octave of
the chorus to a higher key and she did
it
and everyone was like creaming their
pants you should have said no you should
have gone home you should have thought
twice before you let it all go it's
really oh that's cool yeah and then
um
question and
no
invisible that honestly like justice for
those people like those songs are
[__] horrible like I love invisible
so do I but like come on
like I have they got the rain show yeah
so they're fine
um and then last night was I think we
got a rain show when we went to
reputation we did and it was like like
drizzle it was like a Mist it wasn't bad
and our secret song was enchanted
was it mm-hmm I think she just played
Enchanted no I remember like I'm not as
attuned to these things and I just
remember like that we got into something
special I think so no I remember I
remember hearing Enchanted let me know
if that was part of the rep tour set
list I don't think it was because I've
watched reputation documentary like a
thousand times and Enchanted it's not it
no so that's what we got wait that's
like so crazy I know because it's like
not a song you get you know right that's
like a Long Live yeah right right right
I think someone's getting long live I
don't
like I really don't you think there are
some that like the thing is it's like
that would be like her not playing
like shake it off it's like do you know
what I mean or that's like that okay no
sorry that's the wrong it's like her not
playing all too well attended version
and then giving it to one show
but it's not no it is it's like a
special song for the fan base
so like why isn't it in the tour I don't
know
because she only sings one [__] song
from speak now which also makes no
goddamn sense
maybe she's trying to build up hype for
speak now no but like that seriously
like if I could ask her if I ask you a
question if I could ask her one question
and be like what the [__] would speak
now literally like your best album like
we all like love speak now everybody's
about to speak the hell out of now no I
know but like so what we all went to the
era store and we didn't get one era like
we all all we got was enchanted which is
amazing but like what the [__] like I
seriously like I have questions huh okay
it's an intentional thing but you do
still think that peace could happen no
one thing about me is like I know peace
is not happening because it's too
personal to her no and there's like
there are songs that are about Joe and
like she's not singing them and peace is
literally like the one it's so sad so
I'm just like being delusional
yeah read me your list but honestly make
a list my list is kind of like thinning
out because better man was on there the
other side of the door is on there and
forever and always and those have all
been played
um but I would say my second like I
would really not be okay if she's saying
you are in love like I love that song
okay
um long story short as well because if
I'm in the presence of Taylor when she
says pass me I want to tell you not to
get lost in these Petty things you
Nemesis will defeat themselves before
you get the chance to swing I'll pass
away okay
um and the way I loved you
that's a great song so those four songs
are I do believe we will get you are in
love and if you watch my patreon Vlog
you know that when she sang Out of the
Woods she gave like a little speech
before she told us what song it was and
she literally described you are in love
and I thought we were getting it
because she was like it's from 1989.
it's a song where the chorus repeats
itself
you can hear it in the silence silence
silence silence it's sort of a rep and I
was so I was screaming I thought that
was it but out of the woods is just as
good yeah yeah no I'm not complaining
but like I was like like I thought you
know got it okay well Taylor's really
happy and that's our Taylor talk for the
day yeah and it was plenty yeah and
there's gonna be Taylor talk every day
because Taylor's in her tailor era one
thing one thing I mean I'm talking about
Taylor now I spoke about Taylor
yesterday I will be talking about Taylor
tomorrow yeah because Taylor is the news
right now Taylor is the moment the music
industry yeah like and it constantly
cycles and this is Taylor's turn yeah
it's a Taylor's turn about Taylor it's
to turn so we talked about Taylor so
we're taking turns with Taylor and
she'll be back in New York this week I
know oh my God I have to hit the town
every night this week I totally forgot
you gotta get dressed and stay alert I
gotta get dressed and stay alert but
like I can't I'm so tired no seriously
um
I'm making dinner plans like now oh yeah
we have our big dinner plans in two
weeks yeah Jackie and I like have a
double date that we literally scheduled
three weeks in advance like she made a
Google calendar invite and everything
I'm excited but it's a good way to make
sure
you know it's she's just kind of crazy
like the Google Calendar yeah just like
to go to dinner it's crazy but you know
what I'm glad we did it but we're doing
it we're doing it okay our next story
some hosting news some switch up because
beat Shazam has a new host in DJ because
Jamie Foxx is sick going through an
unspecified Health crisis he's
reportedly out of the hospital and on
the mend in physical rehab so we haven't
spoken about Jamie Foxx because nobody
knows what's going on with it and I just
hope he's okay and takes the time that
he needs to get better yeah but usually
he hosts speech Shazam and his daughter
DJ's beat Shazam so the new host while
he's out is the daughter Nick Cannon oh
and filling in for the DJ spot is Kelly
Osborne
Kelly Osborne is a DJ she's a DJ now she
said I've done DJing before but it was
more like making a playlist and hitting
play and dancing around oh so we're all
DJs claim to be a good DJ at all the
house DJ DJ irie was showing me a few
things it took me a minute to get across
all the equipment but by the end I had
it under control
so now she's the DJ okay um I want to
say like Nick Cannon is a professional
host he'll do a great job like
Perfection
um question mark question mark can I ask
you a question why is born DJing a TV
show
like why does Kelly Osborne like
look I'm trying not to be like a hater
but like why did she like keep getting
like good gigs like why was she on
Fashion Place
I don't know I mean it's obviously like
a little nepotism yeah of course but I'm
not against nepotism there's also like
there's plenty of nepo babies in the
industry who are out here hustling and
who are DJs
literally and she's just always is
chosen like maybe people just really
love her maybe she's like a good Agent
good Q score yeah I don't think so yeah
I don't like I I I don't feel one way or
the other no have you seen that clip of
her saying like Spanish people are like
like cleaning toilets all the time like
she's like really like woke whatever and
then she like accidentally exposed
herself as being like incredibly like
she was like talking about like when is
it from from when she was on The View
maybe she on The View like as a guest
okay and she just like she got herself
in like a heated political debate and
she was like well if we don't let in
Mexicans who's gonna clean the toilets
like she was trying to like yeah no and
it was really bad and it's like a clip
it's like one of those clips that goes
viral like every day and it comes across
my Tick Tock all the time okay next time
you see it send it to me I've never seen
it she was like saying she was like
talking about like immigration with
Trump and she's like well who's gonna
clean the toilets at your hotels that's
what she said it's like uh anyone can
clean the toilet like it was like a
crazy [__] thing to say and ever
since then that's like that's where my
mind goes when I think of Kelly Osborne
where does your mind go
foreign
colors and different jobs yeah hair
colors and jobs I like that you know
what I mean yeah and to me she's not
just one thing no you can't put Kelly in
a box no it just goes to like her
sitting at like a pre-pre-red carpet
table Yeah Yeah talking about what she
thinks someone's gonna wear that's
pretty much it that's where my mind goes
we have got to go on beat Shazam you and
I because like we know the lyrics to
every song and we would be so good at it
I used to think like I was really the
perfect perfect person for beaches in
but I've watched a few episodes and it's
really hard it is hard because they
choose like oldies they choose they
don't choose Taylor Swift yeah they
choose like random like Bat Mitzvah
songs like Earth Wind and Fire and stuff
but it's a great concept for a show it
is I still think we would do a good job
I think we could hold our own yeah but I
don't think I would be like the Ken
Jennings of beat Shazam no and I think
like if we go on as a Duo like we
probably shouldn't go on together we
should go on with like someone else
maybe someone older who you know because
someone cover the same we cover the same
faces it's so true yeah but it is a
dream of mine
I feel like manifested CIS that's what
they say that's what the kids say yeah
there's like this thing on Tick Tock
where people like I manifested this
brand partnership I was like um no you
didn't you like tagged the brand a
thousand times like manifesting has just
become code word for begging they're
like I manifested this invite to this
event it's like no well the last time
the brand had an event you were like I
want to go tagging the brand so they met
at you you know right it didn't just
happen from the universe station like
seriously materialized right in front of
you like yeah you worked for it and you
got it yeah you achieved it you didn't
manifest it right yeah that's it another
word means nothing means nothing I I
don't like to use the word and whenever
someone's like now like it's a good way
to end a conversation oh just manifest
it is that what you were doing to me
yeah yeah cool cool no but I also think
this I guess manifest means to like
speak into existence yeah or it means
like a piece of paper with names on it
or it's like something I feel like
there's so many things that people
manifest I'd love to see the list of
things that didn't come true uh
literally my life literally everything
but it's like the one thing that says
manifestation really works I'm like I
hate the word manifest if I see there's
like a content creator who like I was
thinking about following and then she's
like I manifest but you know our media
assist sometimes says it well she's
young and she'll learn she'll learn it's
true I did silly things when I was young
all the time that I regret and she'll
she'll come to regret this this time in
her life she will are you ready for our
fifth and final story is it the fifth
and final story that's brought to you by
Perfect bar yes it is this episode is
brought to you by Perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar that
you know and love and today's a very
exciting day because perfect bar is
launching a new line of protein bars
called perfect bar layers so perfect bar
layers are a new line of crispy protein
bars that are stacked with three
delicious layers and packed with whole
food nutrition they are made with a
crispy base of peanut butter and peanut
and cashew butter they're layered with
dark chocolate or 100 percent real fruit
and then they're sprinkled with toasted
gluten-free oats they're packed with up
to 11 grams of protein and they come in
two delicious flavors crispy peanut
butter and chocolate and crispy peanut
butter and Berry
basically a healthy and delicious peanut
butter and jelly because they're made
with whole food ingredients they're
classic blend of over 20 Super Foods and
they contain no artificial preservatives
perfect bar layers are stored in the
fridge which is something we know and
love about perfect bar you know it's
legit that's why it goes like legit
stuff goes in the fridge crap goes in
the pantry it's fresh you could say that
these bars are stacked and packed if you
aren't already convinced they're also
non-GMO project verified they're soy
free kosher gluten-free and low GI the
perfect bar layers are now available to
purchase online and we have an exclusive
offer just for the toasters all you have
to do is go to perfect snacks.com and
use the code toast for 15 off your first
order that's perfect snacks.com use code
toast to get 15 off your first order
can't wait to hear what you all think
about the perfect bar layers this is our
first time with perfect bar with an
actual discount code so make sure you
head over to perfect snacks.com code
toast to get 15 off your first order
thank you you're welcome our fifth and
final story is a rumored romance that
may or may not be totally true or
totally false but just worth discussing
it's worth hypothesizing Harry Styles
reportedly getting close to Victoria's
Secret model Candice Swanepoel the
crooner has reportedly grown close to
Candace according to the sun quote Harry
is one of the biggest music Superstars
so it's not surprising supermodels are
lining up to date him A source told the
outlet what grandma wrote that he's got
history with Victoria's Secret models
and has been linked to six others who
have all walked in their fashion show
but who's counting
The Insider and that Candace is one of
Victoria's Secret's most successful
angels and Harry would be lucky if he
managed to woo her so let me say I
actually do think this is true it's very
believable it's on track with like
clearly his taste in women who are older
than him and taller than him
um I just want to say
and I don't know if it's because like I
wish this was me you know I am
constantly like uninspired and let down
by Harry's choice in women
okay I agree like he has yet to be with
someone that I'm like that's it that
makes sense but this is so obvious I
just I don't know it's like
who do you want to see him with that's
not you because you're married so that's
why he's not asking you out you
like I don't know just somebody on par
in terms of age somebody like different
I don't know like another model is just
like so and there's nothing wrong with
models I'm sure Candice's great
personality it's just like come on it's
so unoriginal it's just not creative
it's not inspiring but wasn't he dating
like some food chef instagrammer at one
point I remember reported on it um 500
years ago and she had like 10 000
followers yeah and like that was
different I don't remember that's not
what I mean when I say different and you
know what I'm saying okay
look I don't know
I don't even know who I ship him with I
just want him to surprise me
like the reason I believe this is
because it's so predictable you know
yeah
I agree with you I just I don't know I
want something like fun and fresh and
exciting like a
like a Sydney Sweeney type I don't know
you know and I know there's a million
reasons that that can't happen but I
don't know
to someone his age or younger yeah
someone who's like having a moment and
also like
he would someone like young Hollywood
like together they would just rise like
Kaya Gerber if she were single no
kygerberg like it's like a little boring
for me oh okay and she's a model and
you're not into that yeah I just
I'm nothing against models honestly I
just feel like make a list yeah I don't
think there's anyone on like all right
let's use a little more mature because
it's like eligible people for marriage
it's not really
everyone's single and young Hollywood
right Cami Marone
love
love Cami Marone and Harry Styles love
love love I'm just gonna put myself
leave it like leave it that's it there
we go manifest it
I love that's a good couple
and I feel like it'd be honestly a step
up for her it's very hard for who she's
going to date next like everyone knows
her and she's very accomplished on her
own but you know obviously a lot of her
Fame comes from being Leonardo
DiCaprio's long-term girlfriend and
where do you go from Leonardo DiCaprio
Harry Styles Harry style that's really
like the perfect way out of like that
Trope for her yeah
it's kind of how like when Gigi Hadid
broke up with Joe Jonas we were like oh
my god well what's show Jonah's gonna do
and he actually ended up with somebody
on Gigi's level like somebody better
suited for him you know yeah like it was
the perfect way out he could have gotten
pigeonholed like as that guy who once
dated Gigi Hadid yeah but no he got the
perfect girlfriend that is Cami Marone
no Harry Styles is Cami marone's ticket
out yeah I love him too he's taken out
of just like relationships that aren't
working for him no this is like he needs
a little bit of stability he's always on
tour he's the biggest rock star in the
world she's very artistic he needs to a
little bit of grounding I think that the
right relationship could do that for him
and she's like a nice girl I feel like
she's always you know hanging with her
mom she's family oriented I like it I
love it because I like it I like it I
love it I want some more of it I try so
hard I can't rise above it
that's what's wrong that's a beautiful
way to end this show with a
manifestation of a beautiful couple and
a beautiful song from a beautiful girl
stop
um so that's our show one of four this
week reminder there is no show Friday or
Monday because we believe in taking bank
holidays seriously
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the lady Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasting where
podcasts can be found so it's about Five
Guys in today's republics all the places
talented we are hope you guys have a
great Monday love you bye